-Following Disney's recent
announcement of what critics
are calling
the "Don't Say Gay" bill,
which prohibits Florida
public school teachers
from instructing on sexual
orientation or gender identity
through third grade,
many conservative Disney fans
have been voicing their opinion
that the park
has become too woke,
and even going as far as
accusing the company
of promoting
the sexual grooming of children.
Here to talk about it
are two adult Disney fans.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Uh, thank you so much
for being here.
-We were already in the area,
visiting a Times Square Elsa.
-Okay, great.
So, a lot of conservative
Disney fans are upset
that the company is speaking out
against Florida's Parental
Rights in Education bill,
also known as
the "Don't Say Gay" bill.
How do you feel about it?
-Seth, it is a tragedy.
Disney is trying to
indoctrinate our children.
-Okay, and how old
are your children?
-Oh, we don't have any.
-Okay.
-But it doesn't change the fact
that we go to Disney
for the character breakfasts,
not the sexualization of minors.
-Okay, and are you referring to
the fact
that the Little Mermaid
gets married at 16?
-No, that's okay.
-Oh, and Princess Jasmine
was 15?
-That's okay.
-And Snow White was 14?
-The boy-girl ones are fine!
-Okay, so that...
that feels a little telling.
-All we're saying is
that the intolerant left
is ruining the magic of Disney
for God-fearing,
Splash-Mountain-riding
conservatives like us.
-Yeah, but how?
-Take last week, for instance.
-Okay.
Rebecca and I were trying
to ride the Teacups,
and they were like, "Okay,
well, we need to put you
with a third rider."
Fine.
We're very agreeable people.
-Yeah, no, I think
we're all picking up on that.
[ Laughter ]
-So we said, "No problem.
Can you just make sure they're
straight and unvaccinated?"
And this socialist ride operator
was like, "I'm sorry,
we can't do that."
-Well, I mean, it does seem
like an unreasonable request.
-Sorry I don't want
anything gay going on
while I'm riding
a little teacup.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, take the week before.
-You guys went to Disney World
two weeks in a row?
-Yes, we love it,
and we're very normal adults.
So Keith and I
are riding Space Mountain,
and who's sitting in front of us
but a 40-year-old man
and a 10-year-old boy.
How sick is that?
-We were like, "You leave
Pinocchio alone, Gepetto-phile!"
[ Laughter ]
Made a really big scene.
It was really healthy.
-And he was all,
"This is my son.
We're on a family vacation."
Yeah, a likely story.
-That's a very likely story.
-And then when we got off,
the ride operator wouldn't
even say "Merry Christmas."
-Well, it's April.
-My God, you're as bad as him.
-Okay, so three weeks earlier --
-Oh, my God, how often can
one couple go to Disney World?
-Oh, we're not a couple.
We're brother and sister.
-Oh-yoy-yoy.
[ Laughter ]
-So we're riding
the Haunted Mansion.
[ Laughter ]
This is serious, Seth.
-Okay, fine.
Your brother's
making a weird face.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you okay?
-I'll be fine.
-Is he bothering you?
-Yes!
-Anyway, as I was saying...
-Okay. Uh-huh.
-...we're riding the Haunted
Mansion,
and they have this
bride and groom ghost.
-Okay.
-That's the end of the story.
Don't you see, Seth?
They're teaching kids
if you're straight, you'll die.
-I can't imagine that's the
message of the Haunted Mansion.
-Seth, did you know
they won't even let you
pull down Minnie's skirt anymore
to see her mouse business?
-Why would you want to do that?
-To make sure it's
not Mickey in a dress
trying to use
the women's bathroom.
-Okay, you know what?
I think we're done here.
The problem is clearly you
and not Disney.
-Yeah, well,
we got to go anyway.
We're circulating a petition
to make sure Chip and Dale
can't get within 20 feet
of a school.
-Alright, two adult Disney fans,
everybody.
[ Applause ]
-They're not churros,
they're freedom sticks!
-Make Marsha Blackburn
a Disney Princess, you cowards!
-We'll be right back
with more "Late Night"!